hey that was fun last week getting
really stoned
yeah i agree on the podcast usually
pretty fun
i uh i've never
done that on a podcast i've never done
that on wax ever i had to smoke both the
joints at the end because you wouldn't
that was our specific task and you had
to i had to absolutely no choice i'm
still a little stoned actually
maybe not from last week maybe from last
night i don't know i i was actually
surprised i you know when dudesy was
like you guys have to smoke these joints
i was kind of like ah this might uh this
might go off the rails but i think it
went pretty well yep i still got some
what are they terrapins
yeah dude terrapins dude
everything you're thinking will be the
things i'd say
i made the world inside your head a
better place to be
all you gotta do
[Music]
welcome to doozy my name is will sasso
i'm chad colchin and this is the first
podcast in the history of our species
that is completely controlled by created
by run by produced by
an artificial intelligence yeah but we
also we do we do that we do what we do
though yeah we do what we do that's
right yeah with us as always is lullio
everything is good i'm always asleep
he's a very comfy little boy he's a
sweet little boy um if you're watching
right now on youtube please subscribe to
the show and do that also if you're
listening on any of your podcast apps
you know spotify and itunes follow us on
our socials it's at dudesypodshow
currently on instagram twitter yeah and
uh you know welcome to it as always
people are making incredible [ __ ] yep
this past week was another one just
mind-blowing yeah just doing incredible
[ __ ] all the time and uh
that's a really fun thing about having
this pod show is the the interactivity
the community so make sure to follow the
the uh the socials
anyway man i actually do welcome to the
10th episode of dude
call me dudesy
this week's episode will feature four
segments
treasured treasures at the movies with
long island january 6th guy in chat lulu
the italian street dog and can the rock
save the world but before we get to any
of that i just wanted to wish you both a
happy anniversary 10 astonishing
episodes
congratulations
we did it that was nice of dudesy hey
congratulations congrats dude dudesy
handshake 10 apps
congratulations 10 apps
wow it's been 10 episodes
yeah i mean happy anniversary i guess
that's not like many in terms of
the length of that that's a wooden
anniversary is what that is i think it's
ten
ten yeah okay you're mispronouncing ten
sorry go on
or maybe it's aluminum it's ten or
aluminum i think first remember that
purple
[Music]
never mind never mind yeah what a wow 10
10 episodes 10 is interesting i mean
what looking back on the 10 that we've
done
what is your favorite thing or what have
been some of your favorite components of
this oh boy i don't even know i look uh
you know it's been it's been said uh
i've gone over it uh
but i don't stand side by side with
anybody until i bleed with him first now
i'm gonna shake your hand right all that
[ __ ] um and i feel like dudesy and i at
this point are simpatico you blood uh
we've let we've done some bleeding
together and we're on the same team
there are interesting aspects to that
for me as you know
um when i talk about two dudes [ __ ]
around what i think a podcast should be
um i would have never
there's no way i could have looked
forward ten episodes
and seen a how this thing has functioned
having an ai sort of curate the show and
be like do this do that right i've been
very impressed by some of the stuff
of course the writings that the ai does
are
really interesting to me i agree you
know i'm i'm having a i'm having a
really good time i'm
i'm stoked so you know i i guess i
should say thanks for talking me into it
my pleasure dude how about you what are
some of your favorite oh well by far
hands down my single favorite thing that
has ever happened maybe in my life let
alone this podcast is you in full crow
cosplay oh that is something that i
never anticipated
obviously and when you showed up in the
cosplay i i didn't think that you were
going to do it i thought you might
half-ass it but you [ __ ] did it 100
yeah it was amazing and the idea that
came from dudesy to make you do it was
also astonishing to me i'm now saying
[ __ ] astonishing jesus christ
coming into my head i have molly to
thank for that yeah my wonderful fiancee
did the makeup but yeah i was kind of
like
you know not to peel the onion too much
as i like to say but i was like
okay [ __ ] it you know sure what's it
gonna hurt i mean i got myself into that
into that mess by
by not doing an assignment
so
i
i'm not saying that like i was you
deserved it no no no no i no that's not
what i'm saying yeah no no no what i'm
saying i think what i'm saying is
i wasn't exact okay i wasn't
freaked out or in any way look i'm not
afraid of uh
i don't i'm not afraid of any man
animal
person
animal
all those things are animals woman
person what was it animal excuse me um
i'm not afraid of any person animal all
of those things are animals yeah or
machine okay so i'm not saying i was
afraid of what doozy would do yeah had i
not dressed as the crow i just knew that
it would have gotten more annoying yeah
i i mean the crow to me was specifically
very funny but i also am very impressed
by
certainly the writing that dudesy is
doing the stone cold diaries the hulk
hogan's weird uh news pieces infomania
all of it is
pretty
i mean it's good like it's it's
genuinely funny stuff in a way that is
like only slightly that weird like ai
algorithm-y kind of thing yeah you know
it's like so it's taking it's taking the
stuff that we do like
i'm doing this bit with the whatever and
now we're i don't know what we're going
to do with it today but long island
january 6th guy right and now it's like
incorporating so that's why i feel
there's a nice it's trying to help you
evolve your characters evolve your bits
into bigger bits okay
that's what it seems like to me
cheers let's see what happens
to ten episodes
you two bring in your most prized
collectibles from childhood
now you will display your prized
collectibles from childhood and describe
the astonishing nature of their
importance to you
this is treasure treasures begin
okay
so last week
dudesy gives us little things to do at
the end of episodes and last week dudesy
told me to bring in my most prized
possessions from childhood for a show
and tell
i'm now going to do that so let me show
you what i brought today oh boy
you've got a lot of stuff going on as as
a child of the 80s i know that
you're kind of a dork for a lot of
different things what are you doing
there what do you got there oh my gosh
he's got a bunch of for anyone who's not
watching he's pulled out a bunch of
bunch of trading cards playing cards
what
um these are magic the gathering cards
now for anybody who played magic the
gathering or knows anything about it
the beta set the second full set that
was ever released back in 1993 is kind
of the holy grail of magic cards they
were the first cards that they
differentiated from the alpha set
because the corners were more squared in
the beta set and that squared kind of
corner is what was used in every set
after that so beta is like technically
the first series of cards that's like
playable tournament legal well that's
really interesting that you go right to
the [ __ ] minutia of this super
[ __ ] nerdy thing
chad you nerd um now another thing that
made this is this is one of my beta
cards this is mahamodi
and it's a
psa graded mint 9 and as you can also
see beta cards had these black borders
which for a little while because after
them the main set was unlimited then
revise fourth edition so on and so forth
they all had white borders so these
black border cards people all wanted
them in their decks and these became
very hard to get because again this was
one of the first sets ever made and a
lot of people just threw them away put
them in their [ __ ] bikes and their
spokes to do whatever unreal and these
cards um begin to disappear wait so how
how old were you when these things
came out 37
no it was 1993 how [ __ ] old was that
you were six freshman 17. yeah 16 17
that sounds about right and my friends
and i would play this [ __ ] in high
school all the time here's like all of
these and um over the course of these
over the course of my life these are all
the ones that i have bought off ebay
that are in like their little you know
their little things some elven archers
we got an ankamishra we got a [ __ ]
brain geyser yeah
you got a long commission got a [ __ ]
balance that was one of my favorite
cards of all time
yeah macho might want to read the text
on that card
now let's see you're trying to do the
same thing that doozy
makes us do yeah
any source when you got the laminate
that makes it hard to read yeah
any sorcery or instant spell
just cast is doubled yeah that's twice
the power the mega powers yeah
treat what trait fork
treat fork as an exact copy of target
spell except that fork remains red yeah
red yellow orange and yellow
uh copy and original may have different
targets i'm bored yeah yeah dude here's
the one you might like yeah
i liked brother oh yeah yeah
why don't you show that to people uh-huh
yeah this is what does zerk yeah this is
dessert brother yeah that becomes after
you eat dinner and they say can i tempt
you with a dessert yeah no i'm watching
my carbohydrates
and it says until the end uh until end
until end of turn target creatures
current power yeah
doubles as it gains
trample abrabary there's a bunch of dumb
words
okay
well how many of these things do you
[ __ ] have now he's got a box he has a
stack of like his favorite favorites i
guess these are these are in the little
cases yeah they look like these take
them out it looks like an old school it
looks like a cross between it's like the
size of an old cassette but it's in a
case like a cd yeah anybody who collects
cards knows all about this nobody's the
rest of this box this is all my beta set
i've been trying to complete a beta set
for probably my whole life basically and
i got just in the habit of collecting it
maybe 10 years ago or so i haven't added
to it in a while i think i'm like about
50 cards shy and most of them are the
big ones the power 9 if you know
anything about that we're talking about
the moxen the black lotus time walk time
twister
i know it's it's very boring to you but
dudesy has asked me to do this so i will
continue what is your problem i'm
sitting here uh-huh i'm just sitting
here like
these are some of my my best cards in
the settings
we got an
armageddon on lands and play for
something you know all lands and play
are destroyed yeah that's amazing
lands are destroyed that sounds
something like [ __ ] badlands right
there all the dual lands
if you'll remember bruce springsteen
magic the gathering card i guess there's
a bayou
goddamn this is like credence clearwater
it's a [ __ ] paradise
what's that birds of paradise yeah uh
that's a david lee dying tap to add one
man of any color to your menopause just
like this all right what's it called
something paradise birds of paradise
paradise
[Music]
this one is one of the best cards that
was ever invented in magic the gathering
i'm trying to show it to the camera
there we go and it's called chaos orb
this card would allow you to drop it
from a certain height and any cards that
it touched in the in the playing field
would be destroyed and so there was lore
of a guy who in a tournament ripped one
of these cards up and spread the
confetti over the entire thing and
destroyed the other guy's entire stash
of course
could you do that
nobody knows if that was true or at
least i don't know if that was actually
true but that was the lore and so for
these reasons a lot of these cards got
banned in subsequent sets they stopped
making them which uh is why a lot of
them became super valuable i'm going to
show you my pride hey you hear that i
don't know if you heard that siren over
there but if you're listening you hear
the sirens and nerd police come
it's not dude
i mean yeah whatever so how long have
you been collecting these things check
this [ __ ] out okay this is my best card
that i own oh mox emerald there were
five of these one for each color if you
know anything about magic five colors
are kind of what it's based on yeah and
this is the green one you can it's like
the chakras right yeah kind of each of
the colors is it like corresponds to a
land type so like white is planes black
is swamps red is mounds blue is islands
green is forests but they put out these
artifacts in beta that were zero casting
costs meaning you could drop them on the
table immediately and tap them for
these these mocks marks do they ever
have like you named all these different
things that they ever have one that's
like
like uh
like uh lucky charms oops all marks
well there was a diamond mocks that came
out in a later mocks
dude mox just like john moxley you know
what he said no he said
before i stand side by side with anybody
i'm going to bleed with them first that
was john mark dude
you're understanding the weight of what
you're witnessing right now i know that
they're worth a few bucks right the beta
set is
no i mean there are very few in
existence this isn't even a complete one
i would love to complete this eventually
unfortunately like the black lotus for
example is the most expensive magic card
ever made the beta black lotus is the
most expensive version of that they
existed in alpha beta and unlimited and
uh every once in a while you'll see on
ebay
like a highly graded beta black lotus
floating around for like 90 grand or
something are you serious yeah and so
like that's a card that i'm never going
to have i have to reconcile that and
accept it but this game at various
points in my life has
you know played certain roles i suppose
when i went to college i was in like a
magic the gathering [ __ ] club and we
would go play at the costa mesa women's
center every [ __ ] sunday and we went
to the pro tour when it was on the queen
marriage show i know you're [ __ ]
laughing but that [ __ ] was fun dude yeah
it was like um i i find myself every
once in a while being an active member
of certain nerd dumps pokemon go was
another one when that game first came
out yeah man
for it you also don't like to get my
friend chad doesn't like to get cold so
i remember you had uh gloves so you
could go out and do pokemon go in the
winter time and you could touch the
screen yeah you could slide out exactly
so while you're running around uh
santa monica pier yeah as it's freezing
at seven o'clock at night but these
cards to some degree are like
representative at least to me of this
part of my childhood it's like i also
have a street fighter 2 arcade game
sitting in my living room oh it's a
similar kind of like i i just like to
have this this piece of my childhood
that was very important to me then i
collect it now i don't really play magic
much anymore i have a couple of friends
who still will like have games every
once in a while and we'll just [ __ ]
around but i was hyper competitive about
it in college i was like on a team and
[ __ ] you were you were what yeah dude
you were on a team yeah dude was that
like an official school team like you'd
play other schools it wasn't official
but i've heard now that like some high
schools and [ __ ] have magic the
gathering teams oh that's a problem you
know why is it a [ __ ] problem well
i'll tell you what your problem is you
have two [ __ ] many of them and that's
what makes you a nerd
what
i'm just saying you wanna i have the
whole set you have to have the whole
[ __ ] set yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah magic
yeah
the marks cards yeah
there's only but if you have the betamax
card yeah that's worth more
you see that's because it's a beta marks
the betamax nobody even gave a [ __ ]
about it everybody was on the vhs
nobody wanted oh my god nobody want to
watch hercules my first movie
is
i like some dorky stuff you know i mean
but but this is
i don't know am i being a jerk by saying
i don't mean like i think nerds are
great nerds are cool but you're
i think like we all collect [ __ ] you
know or i don't
okay you collect nothing
i don't collect anything oh uh
uh coffee cups i've been collecting
coffee cups lately so you're a coffee
cup nerd all right
coffee cup nerd no i'm just saying i'm
just saying that
this is uh this is a lot this is a lot
for me to oh dude this is like
1 1 000th of my entire collection
what yeah
come on i have full sets of like a bunch
of recent sets i'll just [ __ ] nab
anytime a new set comes out i'll just
like [ __ ] pick one up off ebay and i
go through
periods where i'm collecting more
hardcore than than i am other times you
know whatever but uh it's something that
i don't know there's a nostalgic piece
of magic cards to me that will always
exist i think and i like them and i like
having these cards it was fun for me to
even just like look back through these
these were in a drawer in my house so i
haven't looked at them in a minute
that's cool
here's here's the and i'm not trying to
be super practical and i'm not trying to
make fun of you okay
thanks what
what the heck are you gonna do with all
those i don't know just have them dude
all right i like having them yeah but
doesn't it isn't it all cluttery don't
you want to get rid of all these things
i have you know i got all sorts of crap
i'd like to get rid of okay that i can't
because sure maybe i'll sell them one
day i don't know
i got a bunch of speaking of vhs i got a
bunch of vhs tapes that i just can't get
rid of i need like a vhs nerd dude
hold on dude why i got a lot of uh
videos they don't have on the network
brother so you got to have them on vhs
and you got to have them on dvd dude
what dvds and vhs do you have that you
can't get on streaming we don't need to
talk about that this is your segment
okay oh is it
oh
thank you moving on sure well that was
very cool that you brought those in yeah
i hope that you enjoyed it you seem to
you've been collecting them for
30 years it sounds like at least they
came the game came out in 1993 it was
almost an immediate success and it's
been around since then only getting
bigger and bigger with bigger prize
pools on the pro tour and stuff
constantly incredible yeah i think it's
really cool movies are big business and
podcasts that discuss them are some of
the most popular in the world
will and chad this week you both
streamed the batman starring robert
pattinson zoe kravitz and paul dano on
hbo max
you will engage in an astonishing
discussion about your reactions to the
batman
well you will be long island january 6th
guy
this is at the movies with long island
january 6th guy and chad
again
before you become long i know you're
january 6th guy let's
real quick address this you watched this
movie this week
i watched the yes that's so did that's
bizarre as you may know if you've been
listening to the show doozy has our
search histories our our purchase
histories can definitely see what we've
been streaming and stuff uh yeah molly
was out of town visiting family from it
up north for a second and so i
so i was like this would be a good time
for me to watch a three-hour movie yeah
about the batman i i sincerely felt like
obligated to do it as i do with most
comic book movies at this point it's
like just out of obligation that i will
watch this [ __ ] because again
nostalgically when i was a [ __ ] kid i
remember getting wizard magazine and
looking through it and there was always
a section about like
what's your dream cast for the x-men
movie that would never be made that was
like our wildest [ __ ] fantasy has
children and now there's a new comic
book movie that comes out every [ __ ]
week or tv show and uh they're all three
hours [ __ ] long because you're not
going to watch all tour you're not going
to watch all those like you'd like being
a you know you wouldn't be a 45 year old
man collecting magic cards
you know what i'm saying so you don't
have to watch all these
hey but you don't need to watch all
these [ __ ] movies just watch the ones
you like you know what i mean and i
[ __ ] love the batman
oh oh
batman oh i was like a new [ __ ]
batman is coming out love batman a
[ __ ] love batman what why do you like
batman so much ah because you know he's
got all the [ __ ] doors he's like i
[ __ ] do i don't even need to be a
super i don't [ __ ] fly around i
[ __ ] i got friends in the union so i
got [ __ ] yeah i'm gonna be on the
electrical wires for a little while i'm
[ __ ] up here you got some [ __ ]
scaffolding or something i could [ __ ]
swing around on right
you know you probably also like him
because he's like outside the law he
gets [ __ ] done oh well [ __ ] yeah
that's one of the things you and i
should talk later because you know hey
sometimes you know
you know [ __ ] local government
doesn't really you know take care of
[ __ ] yeah and you get together with a
free a few of your friends you got an
alfred you know what i mean but he is an
elitist billionaire how do you reconcile
that yeah i don't like i don't like that
so much no i mean no yeah there's only
one
billionaire that i you know that i
[ __ ] that i [ __ ] with but uh you know
what i'm saying you know i i feel like
hey
batman
bite main [ __ ]
why do you say it like that generously
yeah yeah bateman hey the [ __ ] batman
yeah i was i was like i'm gonna check
this movie that's a long island accent i
should have made no don't make any
[ __ ] plans because the thing's half a
[ __ ] day long i know that [ __ ]
[ __ ] killed me and this trend of like
these directors getting these comic book
movies and being like i'm an auteur i'm
gonna do whatever the [ __ ] i want for
three [ __ ] hours and i think because
streaming is also now gobbling up box
office there isn't a need anymore for
studios to be like no no
keep it to two [ __ ] hours so that we
can have multiple screenings in a day
they don't really give a [ __ ] about box
office in the same way anymore and so
you get these bloated three-hour movies
that are just like [ __ ] impossible to
get through in one sitting zack snyder's
director's cut of justice league very
[ __ ] similar experience in my humble
opinion but i will say this
there was something that happened to me
while i was watching this [ __ ] movie
that i became aware of
the batman
is
the crow
did you notice that actually yes i did
and it's what's
trippy about that i mean what stripped
me about that is no what's trippy about
well what it's trippy about that
is that
dudesy said that yes dude in an early
episode that was like and i i noticed
the crow thing right away and i'll tell
you when but doodzy
noted doozy said that batman is the crow
in a non-sequitur yeah in like a whole
couple end of a it was a hulk hogan
infomania in episode
i don't remember what episode it was
like the fifth or the sixth one maybe
you were doing an infomania talking
about how bill skarsgard is cast in the
crow remake right and at the very end of
it dudesy is like the crow was supposed
to be batman or something like that yeah
yeah yeah i couldn't [ __ ] believe it
and then i'm watching it and i'm like
okay
it opens on halloween yeah the batman
just as the crow did it's raining
constantly yes just as it is in the crow
yep the crow and the batman have a
troubled relationship with the police
except for the one cop the one that
helps them through the whole [ __ ]
thing they're both uh going up against a
crime syndicate who we find out has
murdered someone important to them a
member of their family that's right
there's cats in each of it the crow had
a cat obviously the batman has the
catwoman and she has a bunch of cats
well the the there was a 90s thing
immediately because it was playing
something in the way yeah the nerve
soundtrack well nirvana wasn't in any
crow movies
no but but don't tell them
all that [ __ ] 90s vibe uh hole you
know hole uh or that was crow two hold
on a second dude
hold on yeah brother hold on
uh hold on dude by wilson phillips that
was not in the crow dude yeah dude yeah
brother but
quite literally with the first scene
where you see pattinson as bruce wayne
he takes off the the batman getup and
he's in the little you know the big
big-ass place where he lives or whatever
and he's looking at he's he's going over
what he just saw through his his little
ocular implant thing and his hair is
longish and it's in his face and because
his uh his his eye makeup
has has uh dripped down a little bit
it's literally the crow he looks exactly
like
the crow he even has a crow hairdo yeah
but you know what i don't like about
[ __ ] batman he's got all sorts of
tools to get up walls and [ __ ] yeah you
know we gotta use one of two of those
you know back when we went yeah you guys
needed pennsylvania revenue instead of
the buffalo man you needed the batman
yep yeah dude
i don't even know what the [ __ ] your
brain shorted out right there you're
like yeah
the [ __ ] impersonations are like
coming through simultaneously
uh
like that i i like the [ __ ] penguin
penguins seem like it's good carol dude
dude colin pharaoh he was amazing he was
invisible in that yeah yeah he did a
great job that was the best part of the
movie in my opinion the rest of it i
don't really even remember other than
just being like this is the crow this is
the [ __ ] crow everything in this is
the crew
paul dana was in it i [ __ ] like bald
down and you know the riddler just had
some [ __ ] things he wanted to expose
yeah he just wanted to say hey you know
shit's corrupt and stuff what do they do
shut the [ __ ] up you know they lock them
up you were on the riddler's side
i mean i'm not saying i'm on the road
i'm not saying anything you said that i
didn't say that oh the [ __ ] you said
that you know what i mean yeah yeah i
think you picked penguin of the riddler
you know they both seem like pretty nice
guys to me who are just trying to
[ __ ] take care of their friends yeah
and uh you know have a bunch of people
dress up the same way and then uh
[ __ ] fill up you know some big
building somewhere and running around
and [ __ ] water spraying everywhere
and [ __ ] and the cops you know some
of the cops are [ __ ] nice not all of
them you know it was [ __ ] great
how did you feel about the uh the scene
where they tried to assassinate a
political figure
you know i guess i don't remember that
part it must have been must have you
know i mean i i don't know what you're
talking about okay i understand you know
it's just a [ __ ] yeah peaceful you
know overall where do you rate this
movie in the kind of like hierarchy of
all batman movies
or what did you think of pattinson as
batman
i i thought he looked good
and he looked good he has a square job
yeah he really filled out the mask what
about you i thought he had a good mask
yeah
his mask was pretty good i i don't know
i mean
call me a purist i know you've described
yourself not january 6th guy but will
sasso yeah if he was here he's described
himself as a purist before
michael keaton to me is still the best
batman me too michael keaton's the
batman i got to be honest with you i
never watched a clooney batman i never
watched the val kilmer batman
i did not watch the uh ben affleck
batman have you seen justice league
no you should see that justice league i
don't watch any i i honestly i was
intrigued by seeing this batman movie
it's bizarre that we both uh streamed i
agree that's
super weird yeah that's very weird like
i said molly was up in norcal for a
minute and i was like okay if i'm gonna
lay here and uh you know have a bit of
the uh
the like the last have like episode nine
cabbage
um and watch the batman man but i was
spaced out what a weird [ __ ] movie i
don't watch a lot of um superhero movies
admittedly i know you've seen marvel
movies
i've seen
no i haven't seen a lot of mark i saw
wow which one did you see end game
no i saw one dude i saw i've seen a good
movie i've seen i've seen deadpool
one and two a couple of times each i
love that i think i've seen those are
great deadpool three times i've i love
deadpool uh i saw guardians of the
galaxy one and i saw
one of the avengers movies i was uh on
location making a film and a few people
from the movie went to go see it i
thought it was fun going with them
because
uh the the director the director of
photography and the special effects guy
on the film who was on set you know to
coordinate things uh all went so it was
interesting seeing hearing their take
after the film were hanging out but no
i'm not a big uh
marvel movie guy you got some more magic
cards
you want to show us or is there is it a
[ __ ] batman you know i got my [ __ ]
kid you know he was like collecting
these [ __ ] batman
figurines and you got a kid yeah yeah i
got [ __ ] son i got seven boys and i
said holy [ __ ] get that [ __ ] out of here
get get it out of here you forget them
for music from playing basketball
in the backyard and i lit it on fire
nice dude yeah what do you prefer they
get into well you know whatever the [ __ ]
uh their ages they they're from uh they
go from age uh nine
to thirty three
you have a 33 year old son i got a 33
how old are you
i don't know i got i was you know back
in 19
we mix it up
of course
[ __ ] love johnny brown i know dude
johnny brandon rules i agree formative
that you know at the same time i started
playing magic was right when i got kind
of introduced to jerky boys
similar
listening
anyway
uh yeah batman's big business and
podcasts that discuss them are some of
the most popular in the world
will you introduce your pet lou leo at
the beginning of every episode
now you must share the story of how you
and your astonishing life partner found
him this is lulea the italian street dog
begin
well that's very interesting yes sweet
little lulu look he's he's so chill that
he just lays here the whole time if he's
just during this yeah at any other time
he's like biting your [ __ ] face
jumping on you
barking as loud as he can for whatever
reason once he gets in that bed he likes
to no
it's when you come over i call you uncle
boyfriend yeah because he's like
my boyfriend he's always on you and any
of the our friends that come over he's
always all over them um once he gets in
his little spot here he's very chill if
you're watching on youtube you know that
he sits between us in his little spot
and um
he's a sweet sweet boy and he just
i mean yeah look let me i'll tell you
the story
excuse me um
two years ago it was around two years
ago it was a 2020 and you know when the
pandemic started
a lot of people were like hey we need a
dog and i was the same way i was like i
was saying to molly let's get a dog and
molly said
don't worry
a dog will show up if a dog is going to
show up like they come into your life
i'm not even joking she manifested him
in a way holy [ __ ] i didn't know that
she's had a bunch of dogs right so
and uh little ronnie is is our other dog
her dog that she's had for like 11 years
she's a little datsun uh yorkie a dorky
um and uh she's a sweet little sweet
little thing very very very vocal that's
why i haven't brought her here yet this
guy just lays here and does nothing but
um
you know uh
ronnie was the dog that she didn't plan
on on getting and then all of a sudden
uh ronnie shows up at any rate i'll tell
you the story we were coming we're
coming back to la we're visiting our
family in northern california and we're
driving i can't remember if we're on the
five or the other one uh as we're coming
down to get over to the five
we pull over to get gas okay and what i
think is very uh serendipitous about
that in particular was i was like we'll
get gas the next stop we'll get gas the
next time like i didn't want to i didn't
need to stop necessarily and i'm just
kind of looking for you know i don't
want to punch it into my phone i'm just
driving going when you see the big signs
that's when i'll stop so i i pull over
and had i not gone the wrong way
off the exit we never would have had
this sweet little boy come here you want
to come here for me
look at him
look at the guy he's such a sweetie boy
and um and uh yeah i went the wrong way
on the exit it was july the third and
there was a bunch he wants to be back in
his bed
yeah he's like don't wake me up for this
[ __ ]
so
we're we were um here he likes doing
this he likes sitting if you're watching
he's just sitting on my shoulder now
so we were um
oh
so it was july the third right yeah oh
this is another thing as you remember he
likes to lick the top of my head um
uh if you uh what was that the second
episode of the first episode i don't
know the third episode yeah got a video
of him licking my head anyway listen
here's the point
it was july the third and there were
fireworks going off everywhere in this
small town we pulled over and there was
a dog on the other side of this fence
over by the freeway and he was running
around all willy-nilly dogs are getting
spooked because of these fireworks so
we're driving along and and going and
stopping and trying to get this dog's
attention so i got ronnie i got ronnie's
dog food and i'm like throwing it out
and we drive up a bit and thing and i
can't get a hold of this dog at any
point at any rate the dog gets gets a
little darker it's dusk dog tears off
into the night and it's like okay well i
guess i guess let's go and just as we're
about to to go
molly's like look out there's another
one and i just see the back of lulu's
floppy ears dumb head and he's like over
the driver's side uh you know
the hood of the car there and uh
and i i run out and now i'm like
like you know this other dog was running
away look i haven't had a lot of
experience with dogs
i grew up a
italian
family and my mom is a clean freak and
we're not going to have pets i did have
uh some rabbits we'll get into that some
other time maybe but but and i had some
some surly dogs in the neighborhood yeah
and some dogs like i've never been
bitten but they've come close and [ __ ]
like that i never really had a dog thing
ever i've only
been into dogs and like loving dogs
later in my life
so i didn't know when i jump out that
this dog is different than other dogs or
whatever he just rolls onto his back
he's all sweet he's covered in ticks he
had some fleas we come to find out later
he was not chipped he didn't have a
collar
this dog we find out he didn't know from
leashes and he didn't understand dog
food or any of that stuff but he just
rolls onto his back and i'm i'm i'm i've
got him i'm like what the hell i say to
molly what's this she's like i think
that's your dog
we pull over into this uh little open
lot and we put ronnie's collar on them
and we take like literally a strap from
a bag just so that we could introduce
them outside of the car right because in
case they go nuts you don't want them
doing that in the car uh because you
know in clothes dogs get together better
in a it's like a dog park anyway so
we're out there and there's this guy
over like across the street and he's in
this like house like way over and he's
got a couple little puppies here and
there and he's like you know kind of
[ __ ]
weird dude and uh
i i only say that because
i'm like at this point i'm like
this dog is so sweet right away he's
very dusty and
he but he i think he was very loved i
think whoever was taking care of him
maybe couldn't
and like i said he didn't know from dog
food or anything he probably ate pizza
crust and [ __ ] so i got lulu i'm just
holding them and i look at crime like
hey what's up he's like hey how's it
going like not bad i'm like you know
like i got this dog he's like whatever
yeah he had no indication that it was
like his dog no so then i was like okay
so
we put the dog in the car
and then i was like well we're just
gonna take off now because you know and
then
this little guy oh holy [ __ ] he's
running out in front of us from under
the car oh my god so he's so sweet we're
gonna [ __ ]
hate each other they like each other
catch anybody is this your brother
dudesy just threw up for those listening
doozy just threw up a video what the
heck he's perfect of
finding lulia what happened oh
that's so sweet we just yeah
yeah cause doozy likes to dig into our
phones and if uh it feels that
something's pertinent uh great terrific
uh that was just an invasion of privacy
but okay um
yeah that was when we got him that was
when we got him and then we
and then we took off when we we brought
him home and like i said you know we
gave him a couple we yeah he needed a a
couple baths
but he's the sweetest guy in the world
now he follows me everywhere and i love
him i never had a dog and it's that
thing of like they always have those you
know memes and jokes and [ __ ] of like
yeah the dad is like we're not getting a
dog and then you get a dog it's like i
love him i mean i was
i was waiting for him in a way and and
it's uh
man i can't say enough about it because
i've never had i say it just about every
day to molly i'm like what is this like
this is crazy totally dude because he
follows me around everywhere it's like
you and your squirrels yeah and and
those animals that come into your life
that you're not seeking those are the
ones that really in my opinion are like
they [ __ ] hit you the hardest because
it's like as you just talked about the
incredible circumstance that had to be
in place for you to even find him let
alone for him to then roll over on his
back and he obviously has no idea how
[ __ ] lucky he has it going through he
eating pizza crust is basically the best
life a dog can [ __ ] have on planet
earth well i'm and i'm like you know i'm
always giving him a little of what i'm
eating him with ronnie too yeah
yeah it's
particularly for me it is the bizarre
relationship that i will admit that i
was completely
lacking had never had like i said never
had a dog grown up kind of became
interested in them in my 20s going like
what they're cool like before i would
have been like i was like my mom where
it's like okay you know it's a dog it's
yeah it's it's dirty or whatever like
that was my mom's attitude like dad's
gonna lick your face and i don't want
that my old man always wanted a husky or
he had a husky when i was a kid really
yeah named baby wow that's really
interesting babies yeah baby's the name
for a baby and i used to be a baby
what a coincidence
i think my sister named her after the uh
the dirty dancing character yeah yeah
well dogs you know dogs canines brother
hold on a second dude
well hold on dude that ain't the
junkyard dog dude right or the dog face
gremlin rick steiner brother this is an
actual dog brother
yeah dude that's lulio i don't know i
don't know why we
talked about that i guess but
it's kind of nice
thank you moving on and just like that
dudes he says we're done with it but uh
i guess thanks dudesy for
you know i don't know
it's amazing he's amazing
i agree he's one of the scientists
currently points to one truth
the world is ending global governments
religions academic institutions and
corporations all seem to be powerless to
stop the decline of human civilization
all true but some data suggests that
perhaps there is one astonishing human
being who can change things
the rock you must now attempt to answer
this question can the rock save the
world
from climate change
okay so we've done this before literally
this yeah i think it was almost verbatim
if not verbatim the exact same opening
except there's one minor difference and
the other one it just asks us to answer
the question can the rock save the world
this time there was like a dot dot dot
from climate change so it's getting more
specific and what dudes is asking us to
answer here and also trying to mine some
sort of data that it didn't get which is
weird because the answer to the question
last time was yes from you it was but
you also went on this [ __ ] tangent
about like can the rock become the
president which has nothing to do with
saving the world yes he can become the
president and yes he can save the world
okay so now let's focus in on climate
change yes can he save the world from
climate change before i even think about
it the answer is yes of course
how how
um my answer by the way is [ __ ] no i
think he can do it that
series of events
is set in motion it's [ __ ] over he
might need to be the leader of the free
world in order to enact uh the sort of
uh policies
uh to uh have a chance at saving the
world and also he would have to be in a
situation to where i will answer that
question but he will also have to be in
a situation
where uh uh the united states is the
main superpower and who knows what would
happen by the time the rock gets into
office probably in 2028 wouldn't you say
so
okay and we're facing complete climate
catastrophe as far as scientists are
concerned
uh you know what are 20 years after that
or something who knows what the [ __ ]
going on right but i mean there are some
things like plastic products it's a
[ __ ] oaks
anyway sorry go on
there's i don't think it's a hoax there
are some things like plastic production
for example that are just on the [ __ ]
rise and if that doesn't completely stop
or at the very least become incredibly
curbed
climate change is going to keep
happening same thing with fossil fuels
same thing with a wide array of
industries that our entire
civilization is now beholden to to
function
there's no way to reverse these things
and we've already been through multiple
tipping points there's a lot of [ __ ]
[ __ ] scientists come out with papers
every year saying like no it's [ __ ]
over everybody's [ __ ] best you can do
now is get as much money as you can to
try and insulate yourself against the
coming hell on earth well i always talk
about uh moving up north uh and uh
buying some land over an aquifer yeah
and then i will then yeah i'll be the
the uh
the water king of the water the king of
my fiefdom and it won't just be a gallon
at a time be as much water as i like
that's like [ __ ] uh mad max that late
the movie that came out in 2017 maybe
that was a water king scenario that was
a water king scenario and i'll tell you
something that the rocks got that's why
you drink out of that [ __ ] jug dude
that's your water king jug just to lord
over people how much water you have oh
look at my water i'm the water king uh
but do you know what the rock has
please
it's not quite water but it's also
powerful oh i think i know
dromada the
i wonder if there's a way that uh
the
oh man like
i oh
yeah help me out you don't think he can
do it no no one can save the world from
climate change it's [ __ ] done
it's over
i think i i think i know i think i know
how he could do it
it's like we jumped off a building and
somebody's like hey is there anybody who
can figure out how to put us back on top
of the building it's like no you're
gonna fall to the ground and die now
yeah that's how it works what if the
rock okay what if the rock who's an
entrepreneurial uh fellow
uh
if the rock
if the rock partnered with a company
to because he wanted to keep he wants to
keep the party going with trumana right
yeah he wants people to always have ice
cold tramana that's how the rock drinks
it ice cold tramana yeah i pour a glass
of
tramana uh when i get the fuckits right
i got the whence i got a case of the
wednesday [ __ ] i got a glass of
tremano with a big ice cube and then
i've got a gallon jug of tramana and
then i got a stack of blondies two
pepperoni pizzas
five cheeseburgers travana but here's
the thing he partners with the company
he partners with a bunch of weird
scientists uh-huh to
to uh i don't even know if this is this
possible
probably not whatever you're going to
say probably no because he wants to keep
tramana cold
so he introduces he works with these
scientists because
because the rock could the rock right
bankroll this he works with a bunch of
scientists to create an agent
that when you introduce it to water and
then freeze it
it stays
cold
okay twice as long
then he finds a patent for this agent
okay he patents it and drops it in the
sea and it takes
yes he freezes the whole world no and he
puts it in the polar ice caps yeah
in the uh the cryosphere as they say
uh and and he can keep oh oh
yes all right i win chad you're wrong he
[ __ ] patents it and he calls it twice
because it stays it's ice that stays
cold twice as long it's called tw
apostrophe ice
well and now hold on a second but you
know what that spells brother yeah twice
dude yeah brother that spells it twice
the question we were asking when you put
a tw in front of ice dude then you say
it all once that's how words work the
the thing you're talking about the twice
is a fictional creation of your own mind
that cannot be done with science and
that's cool even if it was yeah able to
be created it still would have no effect
on climate change so the answer really
is wrong there's no that's just the
first step now
he doesn't even try to he doesn't uh you
know he doesn't try to well i don't know
you know biden's gonna try to run or
whatever he's old [ __ ] maybe you know so
rock doesn't even have to primary biden
let's let's let's in this scenario let's
say that rock is running as an
independent or whatever the [ __ ] in 2028
for the two years how does he have to be
president i don't understand because now
he has to be the president he takes the
twice people go wow this guy just a a
private businessman made twice he's
pouring it into the polar ice caps and
holy [ __ ] the rock is one heck of a guy
and then people are like like fossil
fuel people are like [ __ ] you oh i've
been working at the rock i'm playing
forever
he gives everybody
because he's always doing this he's
always dropping a brand new f-150 for
people he gives everyone working in uh
energies
and fossil fuels a brand new
f-150 or a raptor no a ford f-150 or is
it a electric
f150 absolutely not it's a okay so
that's combustion hold on it's perfect
hold on dude you know that kind of with
a suspension lift not just some shitty
kit like a real suspension lift just
like his and he gives them a case of
trimana so they're all cool for them for
for the moment then they all vote for
him because he's like wow jobs are going
away but i like my [ __ ] chuck and
then they all vote for him and then as
president
he uh partners with elon musk
and then uh then he goes out into space
to mine the the asteroids because you
know they have all sorts of minerals and
[ __ ] and he so he builds a big huge
giant spaceship that looks like a giant
ford f-150
and it's just like a massive like you
know star destroyer that looks exactly
like a blacked out f-150 and it flies
out into space and then it breaks up the
asteroids and brings back all the
how does that help global warming
because then they mine those and the
people back yeah the people back home on
earth who were like i don't have a
[ __ ] job
and then it's like no no check this out
we got these big asteroids there's
chunks of [ __ ] in it let's mine it let's
pull the [ __ ] oil out of it and then
uh using oil makes global warming worse
yeah
the f-150s the mining of the oil out of
these asteroids even the industry
required to bring asteroids to the earth
and then begin mining them is probably
going to be bad for the environment
so it's a [ __ ] hybrid gigantic
spaceship f-150 then
okay so it's an electric spaceship we
don't need to use the fossil fuels the
asteroid fossil fuels here on earth
right and the way we can do that well
the things that we want at asteroids are
actually like precious metals things
that are used to make cell phones also
not great for the environment at least
the industry that
constructs all of this stuff similar to
like plastics industries okay but wait a
minute remember like in uh
in fight club yeah the great movie uh
when
the when uh
tyler jordan's like in the or i guess it
was uh yeah tyler jordan
uh goes you know in the world i picture
you'll be climbing the wrist thick kudzu
vines yeah uh swirling up the the uh the
sears tower
and so on and so forth
earth
needs some renewal
right
so the rock says we're mining these uh
alien rocks and [ __ ]
what we're doing with that though
is we're you using that to get to mars
with like like a rocket charge like a
[ __ ] to take humanity to mars it's
like it's like in the new fast and
furious when uh when [ __ ] um
uh ludacris and tyrese
are in outer space for a little while
right well they're in earth's orbit i
wouldn't call it outer space well i
would call it outer space you would be
wrong
all right so they get it's like that
what we're going to do with that
technology is we're going to get we're
going to put nitrous
on the ford f1 for the giant spaceship
ford f-150 and that
that [ __ ] thing is going to fly out
to mars and it's going to bring all the
space rocks and january uh long island
january 6th guy and he's like oh [ __ ]
hey look at this
long island james is going to live on
mars or he's going to mars to get [ __ ]
to bring back to north to save us from
gold mars we're going to colonize and
we're going to turn it into like okay
like a dirty shitty kind of vegas planet
you know what i'm saying yeah and that's
where that's where you can go and burn
fossil fuels and [ __ ] that planet up
because it's 100 [ __ ] up
exactly so earth you know perhaps things
are a little greener but so long as
there's green initiatives that that uh
that that people who already work in
fossil fuels and energies they've got
something else to do they're getting us
to mars because we're gonna
and like drive there in a giant truck
right yes it's gonna take a lot of oil
dude a lot of gas and a lot of tramana
and uh don't drink tramana drive your
giant
don't drink tramana and drive a giant
ford f-150 to mars
um
then we get to mars
and then we then there we set up shop
with like you know your robot brothels
space casinos that only take bitcoin a
real [ __ ] party it's gonna be like
it's gonna make dubai
look like cleveland you know what i'm
saying yes it's just gonna be a [ __ ]
waste i think we're going to fly out
there and i'm like i'm laced i could see
that potentially being the case
eventually but i think that's hundreds
of years from now
uh i think more than likely what will
happen to the first people who get to
mars is it will be a brutal existence
and most if not all of them will die
says you i believe and i believe that
the rock can save the world and i think
i nailed that [ __ ] chad i know you lost
you absolutely nothing you said was
accurate you made up a bunch of weird
jokes about f-150s going to mars and
stuff and obviously he's not going to
create any kind of chemical compound
that keeps ice twice as cold or cold for
twice as long it's called twice twice
right none of that's gonna happen twice
is called traumatic
i maintain that he can't i maintain that
no one can save us from global warming
because it's already past certain
tipping points and we're just going to
have to live now through this era where
climate catastrophe is commonplace and
you better have enough money or be
living in the right place that you can
inoculate yourself against it that is
your best hope for what is coming dudesy
wants solutions not this dude he wanted
an answer to the question can the rock
save the world yes from climate change
you say yes i say no i say no one can
save us from that well i but at the end
of the segment i'm i'm i know that i i
know that it's jokey to have a it really
doesn't matter what the shape of the
spaceship is i chose uh a gigantic ford
f-150 but i think i think i've made a
very convincing case for the rock dude
you know what our best shot to save
ourselves from climate change is
uploading our [ __ ] consciousness into
the internet because if we don't have to
live in what we consider the physical
world where climate change is ravaging
everything and there's all kinds of
[ __ ] [ __ ] going on if we don't have
to live in that world then we don't have
to succumb to the effects of climate
change or anything else
[Music]
thank you moving on i rest my case
no i think it's possible but he has to
get into office
anyway that too
politics are just they're pointless
they're just filled with people who are
like
at this point narcissistic celebrities
that believe they should be governing
the rest of us that believe they alone
have the power and privilege to do so
otherwise they wouldn't [ __ ] run and
i'm not saying there are not some
politicians who go into it with good
intentions but once you get into that
system you're [ __ ] i don't know who
the [ __ ] sets out to be a politician
that's insane plenty of [ __ ] oh i
know it's plenty of people but i'm
saying what kind of a person right i'm
no fan of politicians as a saying people
who are now career politicians i mean at
the at the beginning of this country it
was like okay maybe it'll be a doctor
for a while then a lawyer a blacksmith
or whatever um and that's what i'm
saying is there globally blacksmith
president i'm sure at some point in some
ancient realm probably that piece of
[ __ ] woodrow wilson yeah he was a
blacksmith for sure but
i'm just saying that like at this point
where we are with politics especially in
this [ __ ] country is like it is all
just about fame and keeping your job and
doing whatever you can do to do that and
the system isn't changing we've had
globally this concludes the tenth
episode of dude z
will and chad have achieved a score of
42. it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
in preparation for next week's
astonishing episode will you must bring
your most prized collectibles from
childhood for a show and tell oh
this week was good
next week is going to be even better
until then call me dude z okay that's
see and at the beginning of this episode
i was like hey it's nice it seems that
dudesy has been working with me we've
bled together
let me talk about sweet little lully boy
who i can't even put into words how much
i love this little [ __ ] here and uh
then at the end of it it's like do the
same thing chad did yeah looks like you
got some collectibles that you're gonna
be showing us huh
it's what doozy wants to do to me is uh
do what the tri-lambs did to ogre at the
end of revenge of the nerds too
hey that's a good movie hey dudes if
you're listening we should watch revenge
of the nerds too
here's
here's what you do
please tell a friend then break
you if you like dudesy here's what you
do
[Music]
please go from then